Hey,
what's going on is bill burn his time for
the Monday morning podcast for Monday,
December 10th,
2019 what's going on?
Ah,
Wa,
you know,
how are you doing? You doing good? That's
good. I'm not my hope you are. I'm not,
you know,
I was going to try to tough my way through
this podcast and smile and act like
everything's fucking Rosie.
MMM.
Oh,
Jesus Christ.
Okay.
It just never fucking ends. It never
ends. It never fucking ends the work.
Never fucking ads. Um, and on top of that,
I sat down and watch some sports this
weekend. Let's get it out of the way.
Oh,
how many you dolphin fans
left the sports by be honest.
How many went out into the kitchen and
heard your one loyal friends still in
front of the TV going,
oh my God. Oh my God.
And then you ran back in like,
what happened? What happened?
Jesus fucking Christ.
Yeah.
That last play of that game, that live,
you know what that highlight looked like?
Not the first guy caught it.
The set or the guy latter lid to that
literally look like, you know when you,
you see an NFL, great. And then you look
at one of his high school highlights,
specifically the running
backs you ever notice.
It's like this 20 people on the other
team, it seems all standing around.
He just runs past all of them.
And you're like,
well why didn't they just tackle them?
Oh cause he's an NFL guy playing
against high school football players.
That happened against my team.
I felt bad for Gronk.
He was obviously in there because they
thought they were going to throw a hail
Mary rather than like a fucking 15,
20 yard pass.
Congratulations to the dolphins.
You fucking own us in Miami
patriots now nine and four.
Okay.
Uh,
I think it's a foregone conclusion that
the road to the circle of balls now go
stroke care. Um, it's
going to be a fun play off.
Um, not for patriots fans,
not the way I fucking defense
was playing, uh, yesterday.
Geez, Tom Brady. Once again,
once again, his dilemma,
how many fucking points
do I have to score?
How many times do I got
to put on the white hat,
gallop in town and fucking save
all the damsels in distress?
How many times he looks
fucking unbelievable,
absolutely shredded the dolphins' defense.
And once again comes away with the loss.
I would love to see he has to have the
record all time record for passing yards
in a loss. 500 yards,
300 yards, 400 yards.
It's fucking it. Four touchdowns, five,
five, three touchdown, five touchdowns.
It doesn't make a difference.
And this age of no fucking difference.
Um,
I'll tell ya,
de France is so bad that they
got drunk playing safety. Um
hmm.
Jesus Christ.
There was so many times in that game
where we could have put them away and we
didn't. So, uh, but you know, it is,
it's a transitional year.
We lost our best running back to wide
receivers, a left tackle in a corner back.
And you know, it takes awhile for
people all to get on the same page.
You Never Deli there now, at least on
the last play of the game. Jesus Christ.
How do those guys even look at Tom Brady?
You know when you fucking do something
like that. Gronk was probably the,
hey, not for nothing. I did
catch one for you today, Tom.
Tom Just fucking glares at him.
Right? He puts on his legs. Um,
yeah.
Fucking brutal. Um, Brian's went
back to back. Huh? How about that?
Fucking a, that guy up there, Hyman.
Okay.
Hitting Charlie Mcavoy,
Mr. Game.
Cause I've been on going to these fucking
Christmas parties and shit out here.
Still ever drank.
Still have not drank fucking 15
days and feel good about myself.
Uh,
fuck it.
Thousand 1002. Oh, I mean Mcavoy, I
think that was his first game back.
But uh, either way, we're, uh,
we're winning games when it games with
the new coach and all that and uh,
I'm open.
I'm going to actually get some time.
I follow them on Twitter or whatever.
I watched the highlights and shit so
I know what's going on and beat Ottawa
tonight to one and over time.
MMM.
I Dunno. I'm just trying to spend
time with the family, baggies g, uh,
but having a great time.
Uh,
okay.
What am I relative spot this
motorized car for my daughter.
And she liked it the first day and
then I don't know what happened.
I think she pushed the button and
it ran over a little foot, you know,
and then she's kind of like,
what's with this thing?
So she kind of stayed away from it.
So finally tonight I just got on the
thing at the risk of breaking it and I was
just going up and down the hallway going
and then finally she wanted to get on it.
And uh,
then all of a sudden then now
she doesn't want to get off it.
It was pretty awesome.
Okay.
Um, she doesn't get steering or
stopping yet, but I just sort of a
okay.
You know, I just sort of run
along with the, you know,
bent at the waist for maximum fucking up,
have my dad back.
You know what I mean? I'm
telling you, your dad,
you got to get one of those
foam rollers every night.
And every morning I'm just on the
floor rolling out my back. It's great.
It's great sometimes in
the middle of the day,
but I must have for like 40 minutes
running around like fucking
Igor and Frankenstein,
like literally a 90 degrees bent at the
waist to try and running behind her,
trying to steer this thing so she wouldn't
drive it to chairs and countertops
and all of this shit.
Okay.
Then when she was done,
I went to stand
up on it.
Just did the AH,
but it was worth it cause that's
my buddy. Um, I also watched, um,
liver Liverpool verse born Mouth,
B. O. U. R N e m. O. U. T. H, uh,
told you I was going to start
watching them. Uh, Jesus Christ,
most Salah four goals.
Does that ever happen?
I felt like I was watching some Wayne
Gretzky shit every time I watched that guy
other than the World Cup didn't
go so well for Egypt Air.
But he scored a bunch of goals and I
really enjoyed it and I got to tell you,
it's raining out once again.
And I had this ridiculous urge to start
drinking some Guinness was some fucking
shots of Jameson and I'm just
like a, you know, it's weird.
Everything about Great Britain,
Ireland, anything over there
just makes me want to drink.
Okay.
Cause I think those are the movies
that I see. You know, bakey blinders.
Don't know nothing about no robbery.
Right.
All they do is booze on that show and
they're not throwing their little sharp
hats at people. Uh, you know,
Ireland is fucking Ireland,
Scotland, you know,
they're up there drinking that fucking
pine tar looking beer. Just, you know,
it's always raining. What do you want
to do on your terrain and out? You know,
you want to start boozing but a really
shit fucking defense in that game or I
didn't I be naughty.
I finally understood that I'm starting
understand offsides a little bit more.
I guess I get it because
the goal is so big.
You can't have people just running
all around. Be fucking great.
If he could though. I think what the,
the, the thing that I would adjust.
Okay.
On,
um,
yeah,
if, if I was, if I was to buy into
a soccer league here in America,
I would make the goal smaller and then
I would just have a blue line in hockey.
And once she got into the zone,
whoever was the fastest motherfucker
to get out front, you know,
he just make the goal a little bit
smaller. Somewhere between shocker size,
goal in highlight, you
know, somewhere in there.
Bigger than an NHL goal.
Obviously it's a giant fucking ball.
Good.
Sorry I'm recording this late at night.
I gotta I gotta be up with
the kid tomorrow morning.
Second. I do this, but uh,
I really enjoyed it. Now what's the
next game? What's the next game we have
out there in fucking a premier
league? Let's see here. Uh,
liver Liverpool.
You can't Liverpool
sure.
Ball
shed. You'll come on,
come on. There we go.
Bump up Blah dude.
And I thought they had another guy.
Oh this one's at 1219.
I need 1218
yeah,
definitely want to see that man.
United game.
Cause I know they're like
the fucking Yankees. Oh,
we Liverpool versus Napoli is going to
be another one of these these football
clubs with the really small stadiums.
It makes me feel guilty for Rutan for
Liverpool to see somebody with one of
those cute little stadiums are like,
well damn I gotta root for these guys.
It was like the Kansas city royals
or the fucking premiere league.
Then they got man United. Then they, then
they are up against wolves. Does not.
I don't,
that does not ring a bell.
Okay.
Is that one of those
little last stadium clubs,
was that going to be one of those
fucking Illuminati Freemason fucking,
it's Kinda creepy logo and kind of
like it Newcastle's new castle. Right.
That's a bigger place. Arsenals arsenal.
I know. Those are the bigger ones. Right?
I think it's some big games,
man. United in ourself.
I recognize them 1216 and 1229
I'll be watching those games,
you know, if I'm allowed to
from allowed to, you know,
you know it was a guy you don't call the
fucking shot still. Yeah. No you do not.
You know. Ah Jeez. What a fucking
weird mass. On a weird week.
It's just sort of a normal week now.
You know,
people dig it back into people's tweets.
Yeah.
You fucking said them when you said this
back on you that you were this person
that you no longer our member when you
fucking did that and then somebody else
comes along or what about these people?
They fucking did that and then
the whole world it's like,
well they have vaginas so it doesn't
count. I saw this fucking lady,
the lady former Miss Kentucky said
naked pictures to a 15 year old student.
Yeah, you watched the slap
on the wrist. She gets, um,
so it works.
That's the world we live in.
They have victims and they never get
punished for some reason I just don't
understand it. And I thought we
were going for a quality here.
It's like if you fuck
up, you fuck up. Right.
Everybody gets fucking the same
fucking pound of flesh taken. No,
cause that now works.
I Dunno how it works.
Okay.
All I know is now is I'm
feeling like this is like,
it's going to become a world where
it's just like, ah, you know,
I'll kind of do that job, but I don't
want to be the guy doing the job job.
I'll be on the outskirts of the guy doing
the job cause I'm, I'm not going to,
you know,
okay.
You know,
people just,
I don't know this whole fucking
world now where like people are just,
Oh that guy's successful
or she's successful level,
let's go back and let's just try to
fucking ruin whatever they're doing.
I think if you fucking do that,
someone should go back into your life,
interview a bunch of people and let's
see if you're a good fucking person.
Because if you're not, I mean,
what the fuck's going on?
Then you just bring in a cunt.
He just upset because somebody
else has something that you don't,
is that what it is? I Dunno. Anyways, so
today I went to this awesome birthday
party. It was a friend of ours.
So we go over there, my lovely life
and my beautiful daughter. Right.
And
it's like a two year old birthday.
So we fucking go over there and uh,
we're having a great time.
And then there's one big kid there,
she's like six years old. She's like the
oldest sister or somebody or whatever.
And she's got like this giant like
not like doll house. It's like a,
I got tree fort but it's on the ground.
You know,
it's like a doll house that
a kid can go into the fuck.
Do you call that clubhouse? I
don't know what it is. Right.
So she's in there in the, in the dude
like whose daughter was hooked it up,
had like a doorbell and had a sign with,
with the six year old girl's name on it
in a little phone jack thing in there.
I mean this thing was,
was awesome.
So she was in there and she was like
preparing breakfast or whatever and oh my
God,
did I bomb in front of this six year old?
Every time I went left I should have
went right, right. It was hilarious.
Like I sat down,
I was standing like watching my daughter
going in and out of the doors, right.
And then she announces,
she goes,
I made pine cones for breakfast.
So I see this little seat that you sit
outside almost like a for a serving
windows. So I sat down,
I said, oh, I go, thank,
thank you very much for making
me a pine cone. She goes,
I didn't give it to you yet.
And I went, Oh shit. Sorry.
So then she hands it to me and I go,
thank you. I go, how much is that?
And she goes, it's not for sale.
She goes, they're not for sale.
And I was like, oh, all right, sorry.
I thought it just struck me as like a
little lemonade stand. I'm thinking,
it's like, all right. And then she
looks at me and she goes, it's 1250.
So then I pretend to count out
$12 and 50 cents. And she goes,
now that's not what it costs.
She goes, that's what time it is.
Like, Alrighty then I'm
going to leave. Cause, uh,
evidently I have the intellect of a three
year old because you're destroying me.
She got me three times in a row. Thank
you for making me, uh, for the pine cone.
She goes, I didn't give it to
you yet. How much do I owe you?
It's not for sale. It's
1250. Here's your 1250.
That's not the price. It's the
time. I was just like, wow,
this takes me back to when I was in
school. Whatever I said was just,
was just, it just, I don't know.
But anyways, I still had a,
a a great time,
you know,
daughter figuring out some stuff,
how to go down the slide and
all of that stuff. And um,
you know, kids, they kind of go to
this thing, we're in the beginning,
they're like really outgoing.
At least my daughter was.
And then they get shy and then, you
know, we got her to be outgoing against.
So it's kind of cool watching
him do that. And I was, you know,
it's kind of cool cause I was like in the,
I was in the valley area kind of
out by Van Nuys Airport and um,
just the way the wind was blowing,
you know,
the planes would an off to like I guess,
I don't know if it was the north,
but sort of not towards lax.
They were headed the other way and
they'll kind of going over the house,
which I thought was awesome.
And then I looked in the alley and
there was a guy with like this one floor
house, any heat. He had a
wind sock on top of his,
a on top of his roof. Um,
and I'm thinking like,
is that guy like a pilot?
Like what?
Like who the fuck could
see that from the air?
But in a way it was kind of
cool that he was doing it.
Maybe he's a pilot and he
goes out and he'd just,
cause he takes off from there and just
kind of a straight shot down to the
airport.
He just sort of looks at it,
but then he could just listen to the
fucking 80 said anyways to know which way
he's going to take off.
I Dunno,
I just never seen a wind sock on top of
anything other than a skyscraper or at
least someone with like a Helo pad
on it. For those of you, you know,
don't want to talk about it just basically
shows which way the wind's blowing.
And you always take off
and land into the wind, um,
for optimal performance.
Um,
and the last thing you do is you
don't want to have it at your back.
That's not a good thing. Um, anyways.
Uh, but we were driving up
there and it's just like,
I always knew people drove crazy or I
don't like driving on the highway with my
kid. I just don't people out here, if
anybody out here is listening in La,
you know,
I know this isn't going
to make a difference cause
there's so many of you guys
out here, but like that fucking shit will
you pass people on the right hand side.
You really gotta be key. You're going
to fucking kill somebody. You know,
you passed somebody on the left,
the further left you go,
the faster you go.
All Right,
the furthest left that you can go.
That's the people driving the fastest.
You don't drive that fast
in the first fucking lane.
Somebody is trying to get off the highway.
They're making their way over.
Now all of a sudden they got to be going
like 80 miles an hour to get off the
fucking highway. What are you doing? Um,
I just think it's because this,
there's so many lanes late til like six
lanes out here on either side that I
think all the rules,
it just becomes,
I don't know what it is and
there's so much traffic.
I just feel like people are just
like, oh my God, an open fucking lane.
I can go a quarter of a mile and not
have to hit the brakes. And they just,
they just fucking
slammed the gas down.
Whatever the hell it is they're
doing. But um, it's really unsettling.
And then I'm sitting there with any,
I don't want to fucking snap and I can't
kiss my kids in the car cause I don't
want to fucking be that guy.
Um,
I dunno dude. But anyways, I'm doing
some benefits out here this week. Uh,
I believe Thursday night I'm going
to be up at the ice house and on a,
then I'm also doing one at the,
uh,
the Fonda theater for, um, for, uh,
who the hell is it for the comedy store?
So that's what I'm doing this week. I've
got a couple of those things. I mean,
I gotta be doing my,
try
to take some time off
before I go to Europe,
but I also have to be on my
game when I go to Europe.
So it's sort of a slippery slope,
but I got a bunch of new shit
that I want to talk about.
I can't wait to talk about
it. Uh, get on stage here. Um,
tomorrow night I think I'm going to head
out somewhere here in La and tried to
get on some stage to get some stage time,
I should say.
And I still have not fixed
my headphone Jack here,
but I am done flipping
out about it because
yeah,
I'm trying to be a
better man. Um, anyways,
so when somebody gets, so when some
woman gives a speech at an awards show,
I could sit there nodding like, yes,
I did the work. I've done the work.
I understand now. Uh, simply safe.
Everybody makes sure nothing becomes,
make sure nothing comes between you and
protecting your family this holiday and
save hundreds of dollars while you're
at it with simply safe home security.
Uh, if a storm takes out your
power, simply safe is ready.
If an intruder cuts your phone line,
simply safe is ready.
Say They destroy your
keypad or siren simply.
Staples still get you the help you need.
These guys are like the terminator.
Nothing stops them.
Maybe it's overkill.
Maybe it's the last thing you
want to think about this holiday.
But with simply safe, you're always ready.
Simply safe believes nothing should be,
should get between you and
protecting your family.
That's why they only charge
you what's fair, what's right.
1499 a month, no contracts, no markups.
It's easy to install.
You'll have your system up and running
in just minutes and today you can save
hundreds of dollars on that protection.
If you go to simply safe burg.com that's
simply safe bird.com but hurry this
holidays offer offers ending soon,
simply safe bar.com that's a
great thing to get because, um,
everybody knows you. Everybody
knows this next, you know,
real is this fucking real
estate bubble's going to burst
these stupid luxury high rise apartment
that every politician is letting go
through. Just build it up.
It's good. Gives people jobs.
Just keep going. It's all our money. Put
it out there, put it out there. Overbuild.
Make more than what is needed.
MMM.
I mean out here in La, I swear to
God, it's like every other block.
They're just knocking shit down and then
putting up a luxury high rise apartment.
Um, and they're forced
to and like, you know,
they're are forcing people out and I
don't know where they're going to find all
of these rich people. That shit. They're
like seems to me that's like for the,
the upper 10% of people.
And it's 100% of the buildings that
seem to be getting built out here.
MMM.
I Dunno what the fuck.
I know I'm just a goddamn comedian,
but I would invest in simply safe because
there's going to be a bunch of fucking
homeless people trying to
break into the house. Uh Oh.
Bateau though to Mandy's Mia.
Andy's get far can simply save.
Do Dude, dude, dude. Brds
brds then you're safe.
And that is great.
Get some barbed wire and a fucking BB gun.
You sleep during the day.
You shoot.
Never Fun when the guy sticks his head
through your fucking screen window with
your fucking velvet balls in his face.
You're really comfortable. Me undies,
the coveted micro modal modal fabric,
which is three times softer than cotton.
They've never felt this fabric.
Keep your hands to yourself.
Get ready to experience pure
bliss and underwear forum. Um,
you can also get a style that is
perfectly suited for you or that special
someone, men and women can each
choose from four different cuts,
all of which are available from
classic colors too. Adventurous prints.
Seriously these fun Arby's
yon and my crazy here. These fun on
these would be a great stocking stuffer.
But why stop it?
Andy's Mandy's has cozy lounge pants and
Wendy's in that same super soft fabric,
perfect for wearing Christmas morning.
Mandy's has a great offer for my
listeners for any first time purchasers,
when you purchase any me on these,
you get 15% off and free shipping order
by 1216 for free shipping in time for
Christmas crunched for time. You can't
go wrong with the me Andy's gift card.
This is a no brainer.
Get 15% off a pair of the most comfortable
undies you will ever put on to get
your 15% off your first pair,
free shipping and our hundred
percent satisfaction guaranteed.
Go to me undies.com/ [inaudible]
that's [inaudible] dot com slash bar.
Okay.
Oh, lastly, but not leastly.
Uh, what is this here?
A stamps.com,
uh,
talk about how the holidays are
always the busiest time of year.
It absolutely is.
Everybody's got to go out shopping
whether they liked it or not.
Okay.
Um, what do you have on your holiday
list? And I still have this fucking head,
phone, Phone Jack, whatever the fuck
you call it. When I learned what it is,
then I feel like I can order it,
you know,
as opposed to just ordering a bunch of
shit that sort of looks like it. Um,
is it a jack?
Is it an adapter?
Yeah.
Um, I don't know what it is. Uh,
what else do I have on my list?
Okay.
I Dunno. I really don't know what
the final, I know I have something
we wish you a merry Christmas
cause it's called outside baby.
It's cold outside.
Okay.
What do I have for, what is my wish
for Christmas? I wished it all.
Or do you guys have a very merry Christmas
and that they tried and tried to take
any music away from you.
You know,
they're going to start with that song
and I figured about three months they're
going to go after Aerosmith
for walk this way. You know,
she could walk out
whatever way she wants to.
MMM.
Maybe a couple of books.
I'm reading a book right now,
Bob Cousy and Bill Russell
that I'm really enjoyed. Uh,
I'm telling me to get back to books.
I keep threatening that I'm going to go
back to church and start reading books
that are going to go back to church.
Then I'm gonna start burning the books
that I'm reading and then I'm going to go
to a remote island and get
shot with bows and arrows.
That's how I'm going to go out. That's
my, that's on my Christmas list anyways.
How many errands do you have to run a,
I got a couple more.
How is stamps.com helping you save
time this holiday season? Well,
once I buy this shit,
I don't have to go to the post office.
I could just mail it from my house,
you know.
Anyways, as you know, the holidays
are the busiest time of year,
especially at the post office.
That's why you use stamps.com.
It saves so much time during the hectic
holiday season. You stamp stop calm, um,
to send all your gifts out. It's perfect.
Wrap 'em up, send them out, see you later.
And right now you too can enjoy the
stamps.com servers for the special offer.
That includes a four week trial plus
postage and a digital scale without
longterm commitments.
Go to stamps.com click on the microphone
at the top of the homepage and type in
[inaudible] that stamps.com enter bar.
You know,
I really wonder how the fuck these guys,
I don't know.
We will be screaming and yelling about
shit that's in people's Twitter feeds.
And meanwhile,
the bankers are about ready to fuck fuck
over another generation of retirees.
And once again, they will not go
to jail. You know what I mean?
And I got to fucking sit here and
listen about gender neutral bathrooms.
You know? Do you know what are you guys
have in your house or your apartment?
You know what you're already have.
You have a gender neutral,
a fucking bathroom.
As long as you got to sit down toilet.
I mean,
that pretty much covers the
entire spectrum of way a
human being can go to the
bathroom,
you know?
But I want to find that
half my fellow at on it
me, while they're building another luxury
high rise apartment with fucking old
people's money, our money and our will
live long enough to fucking get out of it.
I don't know what the fuck
we're doing need to do, man,
is we need to legalize weed at a federal
level and we need to export it and we
need to get the world high.
So they like us again and
then we take all that money.
We pay for this never ending war.
And then meanwhile we get onto some sort
of fucking electrical and solar power
even though at the end of the
day it's probably not cleaner.
But what it will do is put all these
fucking people out of business because
won't have any oil money. They'll
pay the Turks they want to go is up.
Why don't we do that?
And everybody will be having
a Holly jolly Christmas.
It's the best time of the year.
Buba to beat [inaudible].
I don't know if they'll be snow.
I'm gonna see you guys some carols,
but have a cup capa. Cheer.
All right. I been dealt with,
we got some good emails this week.
MMM.
I have no idea. Oh, oh, I want to
thank rich eyes. And by the way,
for having me on his show, I had a
great time, man. He's such a good dude.
Just a really good fucking person.
And uh,
you know,
all the people that are over,
they're hilarious.
I had such a fun time on that show. You
know, they were saying how Peter was,
you know, it was raining
crazy that day. And, and,
and I guess they got some sort of
warning where they were saying, you know,
Peter was saying,
you know,
you shouldn't say it's raining cats and
dogs any more because if they actually
were falling out of the sky
from a rain cloud, they get
hurt. It's just like, yeah,
well we understand gravity, but
that's never happened. Okay.
So of course I went in there.
Okay,
how do you not, you know,
it's like Jesus Christ,
it's raining cats and dogs out there.
It's a frog.
Strang you could drown a fucking moose
out there. Um, and I love animals.
You know, I love animals as
much as I hate pushy cunts.
Uh, yeah. Pushy fucking cunt. All
right. Wikipedia searching. Hey,
is sweet Billy boy wanting to give
you a hand with your search engine.
Always using Wikipedia.
Oh God bless you.
If you use Firefox or chrome,
there's a setting in the
options. Of course, I don't,
uh,
or settings.
Chrome for choosing the default search
engine is when you type in your location
bar.
Yeah.
Oh, wait a second. Well, let me see.
All right, well I'm, I'm on Safari.
Okay,
let's see. Preferences. All right,
here we go.
Page 100% zoom.
Okay.
Never use font size.
Smaller than nine.
Okay.
Internet plugin show menu,
change settings,
style sheet. Nothing selected. Am I
going to fuck this whole thing up?
Okay.
All right. Obviously this isn't
all right. Tabs, general passwords.
Privacy's notifications, advanced. No.
Windows new tabs.
Home page.
Okay.
Is apple.com oh, I can change
that. I know. I could do that.
Um,
remove history.
Okay.
Oh,
Jesus Christ.
Okay.
Search. Oh, search. Here we go.
Search engine is Google.
All right.
Yeah.
Well,
where the fuck
Goddamn a you motherfucker
and they'd never works. Why?
Why would it work for me?
All right,
well that was a big swing and a miss
bookmarks develop window.
I have no idea.
Everybody, if you listening,
it says Safari, then it says
file edit, view history,
bookmark, develop, window help.
I'm not going into help.
I've done that too many times.
I fucking ask a question and it never
answers the question that I fucking asked.
You know, I've just been hurt too
many times. Do you know what I mean?
Do you know what I mean? It's just
one of those things. Uh, all right.
The first known decorated tree. Oh,
Christmas tree. Oh, Christmas tree.
How lovely are your branches?
You have fucking there.
You're really a shrub in a month.
Be a nub cause you won't get water.
Then you go out in the trash.
It's like a puppy mill for trees.
Oh,
Christmas tree lyrics. Let's see here.
Well, let's take me to
Wikipedia. Uh, okay.
And so Christmas tree, oh,
Christmas tree, a lovely yards.
Xy branches. Jesus. Some of the
powdered wig wrote this one. Oh,
Christmas tree. Oh, Christmas
tree just felt the letter o not o.
H how lovely are thy branches?
Ben Franklin is a fucking drunk.
Paul revere. Bages horse. Oh, Chris.
Smell these original
lyrics. Oh, your bows.
So you're both so green and summer time.
Stay bravely green and winter time.
Oh,
Tan and bomb. Oh, Christmas
tree. How lovely are there?
I don't know what a bow is.
I don't want to tan it. Bomb.
That's like a rich person's last name.
Mr [inaudible]
right now I gotta look,
I got a few to Tana bomb is now.
They just start fucking singing about it.
That's when you know you were under
the holidays when you know what all his
fucking shit means.
You know those Martha Stewart type chicks?
You know the fan girls
that really liked keep up,
but they'll know how to make it and ball.
Okay.
Oh,
bomb is a German Christmas song based
on a traditional fast and what I want
Wikipedia you fucking
intrusive. Cons. Oh Tana Boggis.
It's all one thing. Oh,
Tannin ball. Oh wait,
did they ride? Oh, Christmas tree.
I guess all that means is all
that means tree in, Oh shit.
When I go to Germany next month,
I'm gonna have to sing that to all those
fucking crowding and sons of bitches
over there.
Oh,
old Tynan bomb. [inaudible] bomb, um,
is a German Christmas song based
on a traditional folk song.
It became associated with the traditional
Christmas tree by the early 1920s and
sung as a Christmas Carol.
The modern lyrics were written in 1824
by leaps zig by the leap Sig organists
teacher and composer Ernst options.
Shush.
A Tannenbaum is a fir tree.
The lyrics do not exactly actually
referred to Christmas tree or describe a
decorate Christmas tree.
Instead they refer to the first evergreen
quality as a symbol of constancy in
faithfulness. Oh, I see.
This guy was alone in the woods, started
having fucking failings about a tree.
You know what I mean?
Yet we still complain in this country
crisis. People in Germany, right?
And songs about trees. Well, I
guess we have tree huggers here.
You know,
eventually whoever the pita is for trees,
who's at fucking Greenpeace,
you know,
they're not going to like the expression
tree hugger because the tree has no say
in that physical contact.
So in a way it's a form of assault.
Um, all right. The first known
decorated Christmas tree, dear Billy,
ghost of Christmas past. I really
do look like that though. I did.
You know that on your tour of Europe
you'll be stopping in the city where the
oldest recorded decorating of a Christmas
tree went down. I didn't know that.
Ragga or Riga,
Latvia.
That almost sounds like two
characters on fucking taxi.
Riga and Laca Riga,
Latvia.
Heard a friend talking about it
and immediately thought of you.
What's your favorite way to
decorate a tree? I quickly,
uh, without my wife in the room
telling me I'm doing it wrong.
Um, what else? Um, I dunno, I, I,
my favorite way to decorate tree
would be a, with my lovely wife,
with some Eggnog, with some Christmas
music on a little booze in the egg.
Nog We do a little slow dance.
I kiss her under a missile toe,
you know,
one of the last year she can do that
because that's a major crisis for white
women that you know, that there's
mistletoe out there, I guess. You know,
they really have a lot of problems and
that's like one of the ones right on the
top of the list.
You know,
I mean forget about climate change and
that swirl a trash in the Pacific Ocean.
Can't even say it.
I think what we need to get down to first
off is what's the deal with mistletoe.
Um, okay. Anyways, I, uh,
when you have camel toe
during the hozzle holidays,
is that called mistletoe reverse?
Mistletoe upside down. Inverted mistletoe.
I Dunno. Uh, when I was a kid we made
ornaments in school with macaroni. Yeah.
Then you'd spray painted gold.
Okay.
Uh, macaroni glitter and
white glue and shit like that.
I doubt that they do that anymore.
Thanks and love to you and
the family and the mom,
Photoshop guy who lets me see
you and all your imaginary glory.
Uh, yeah, we use those used
to be a thing like, um,
I made, you know, yeah, you still make
ornaments. I remember there was one,
it's like it took a coffee cup.
Okay.
And then some, one of those
pipe cleaner things, you know,
you cut a hole in the bottom of the cup
and yet I know somehow you ran a piece
of macaroni and it's supposed to look
like a bell and the top of the pipe
cleaner coming through was the handle.
Then they,
then they would make a cardboard cutout
of a little or a paper cut out of a, uh,
a Christmas tree. Then you put a bunch
of macaroni on it for whatever reason,
macaroni was a big deal.
You'd glue it to the paper and then you'd
spray painted gold and then he'd give
it to your mother.
And she looked at it like,
that is the ugliest fucking
thing I've ever seen.
But my kid made it and I loved my kids.
So that will now go on
the fucking front door
until you're 47.
Um,
yeah, I dunno, I'm not,
you know, I like ornaments.
I wish we had a lot more of them,
but like I don't like
those Christmas tree shops.
They creep me out and like really
people that, that go in there are
weird in a way that I'm not weird.
And what however are weird is it
just fucks with my weird and I get,
I get all weirded out man. And I just
fucking, I just leave. I can't do that.
You know,
I'm trying to get to the point where I'm
not saying that there were a bunch of
fucking Weirdos in there
cause I know I'm weird. Right.
But I go in there and it's like a,
you know, plus I don't like
clutter. I don't like a bunch
of shit around my house,
you know what I mean?
Yeah.
It's like those people that like,
you know,
he'd go buy somebody's house and
every year they have like, you know,
those figurines and shit that
they put in the front yard.
And every year you see the same
ones and then they add a few more.
Okay.
Yeah. Have you ever thought about like
where the fuck do they put those things?
The other 11 months of the year.
Like how much of that of the garage is
that taking? Like it's the middle of July.
It's hot as shit.
You going in there,
you're trying to find the cooler and
then you're walking by like reindeer and
snow men and all that. That's just, that's
just, that's too fucking weird for me.
You know, I don't want to step
over that shit. Right. I just,
we just have like,
we just had the Christmas tree lights and
then we just put the bulbs on it and I
put them on the tree and my
wife's stands back and she, uh,
well this year she did it that way. You
know, she always decorated in other years.
This year we've got the kids,
so she was just kind of holding her and
telling me there's too many blue ones
there. You need a little more red
and then put some green over there.
And uh, you know, so there was that.
I probably would enjoyed that more if I
was boozing. I'm not going to lie to you,
but, um, but I didn't, I wasn't,
I've been drinking my eggnog straight
this year with the little shot of nutmeg.
Okay.
And, um, if I sound bored shitless, I am.
Yeah.
It's this time of night, it's nine 10
at night. This is the time of night.
We'll usually, you know, I'm having
a good time and I just don't anymore.
But I will tell you in the morning's
the best thing about being sobers the
fucking morning, you know, you wake up,
you feel like a fucking
million bucks and um,
okay.
Yeah, I dunno. Anyways, it's
always a weird time of year.
I love the holidays and
it's also depressing that
another fucking year went by.
But then the second is January 1st
and like, it's all ahead of me.
I'm going to make those changes.
How many to become a better person?
Uh,
if air,
okay,
why not buy,
see a dear Billy frisbee frown.
I don't even know what that means.
I don't want to know about that means.
I don't know. I don't know that. I don't
need to know that. My frown is weird too.
I already have enough physical
fucking hangups. Frisbee frown.
I'm bill.
I'm a,
I'm a little behind on the podcast since
I watched my one year old girl fulltime.
Oh yeah.
But you hit the lottery.
They're the best and have to censor
what I play in my house now. Yeah,
yeah. I understand that. Um,
he says a little while ago you were
explaining that you choose not to go into
the ocean saying that it's an unnecessary
risk and basically that we don't
belong in there compared to the
other animals that do belong.
I don't disagree with you.
Okay.
But I am just wondering by that logic
how you justify going after your pilot's
license license or whatever it takes
to fly your worldly birds and the like.
I was hoping you would compare this
while you were talking about it,
but I don't think you ever did.
Obviously as humans we take a
lot of crazy risks every day.
Like just getting in a car and going
70 miles per hour. Yeah, I know.
And doing that in the left hand lane and
all it takes is one fucking asshole and
the other side you ever see that shit or
where the t the the fucking 18 wheeler
jack knives and comes
over on the other side.
Okay.
You know, I got the kid in the car now
so I try to stay in the right lane,
but everybody's doing 90 miles an hour
out here on it. I'll try. It's crazy.
Anyways,
but I would like,
I would think the pilot thing would
fall under the same category is taking a
swim on the beach.
Thanks as always for the great podcast.
My wife always knows if I have you on
my headphones by the stupid grin on my
face, go fuck yourself. Um,
great question sir. Um, well,
the reason why I got a pilot's license
was because I read up on the banking
system and realized that it
was a giant Ponzi scheme.
And I was afraid because of how
dysfunctional the city that I live in is,
you know, you can barely get out of it
when everybody, when it's all working,
forget about if the shit hit the fan,
how would I get Outta here?
And the only way I could think was
okay
to learn how to fly a helicopter,
get up and get out.
Now I did the first part of the plan.
Now the major part of the plan is to
actually have access to a helicopter close
by.
MMM.
You know, that's why I did it.
And uh, but I will tell you,
it is a, a, you know, there
is an element of danger to it.
But now that I have my kid,
I don't solo that much.
Every once in a while I do just to, you
know, just to know that I can do it.
But for the most part I just,
I'll fly with an instructor and,
you know, I don't do anything crazy.
You don't fly and like,
you know, you know,
wins beyond a certain amount of knots.
And I also will tell you though, it's way,
way, way, way,
way safer than getting in a
car and going on the highway.
And I have experienced both and
I can tell you like, you know,
there's nobody up there. I mean
there is, but you know what I mean.
But there is it and it's like
we're talking to each other,
we're in the same airspace
and we're announcing our
position and where we're at.
Okay. And if we don't see each
other, then you take offensive moves,
I guess a defensive move,
your proactive like at the guys at the
same altitude. You just tell them, well,
okay, I'm going to ascend 200 feet
or whatever the fuck you need to do.
And then even if you don't see
each other till the last second,
you literally like hundreds of feet
above or below him and it's fine. Um,
there's no radio contract contact on the
highway and you are basically flying in
formation with people who are on meds.
They're texting,
they didn't get enough sleep.
They suck at driving. They don't,
maybe they're really good at driving,
so they're driving like a fucking lunatic.
Like everybody else is as good as they
are. Those people are probably more,
even more dangerous than someone just
sucks it driving and drive slow. Um,
and there's a lot of
times that I've, you know,
finished flying,
flying solo and landed and got in my car
and within two miles of going down the
street, I watched somebody just
fucking t-bones somebody else,
somebody go flying off a fucking scooter
and land on my side of the fucking road
and slide on their face. So we just
driving in the left lane and didn't,
for whatever reason, just veers
into the fucking, they were texting,
weren't paying attention, literally
slammed into the median between, you know,
both sides of the highway.
Fortunately stayed on this side of
the highway so they didn't, you know,
go up and over and kill somebody
and literally just went spinning.
Okay.
Three 63 63 it's like five,
three sixties across six
lanes of traffic before slam.
Like a stock car accident.
MMM.
Nobody near the guy. Just fucking
did. I see that all of the time,
so I understand what you're saying. And
I have to be honest with you, like, um,
it is an unnecessary
risk. Um, but I find it,
I most of what I say about the oceans
because they have such a tremendous fear
of it and I just can't get over
that. All of this shit is, you know,
I'm treading water with my head
above it, you know what I mean? And,
and everything else is like,
I don't know,
did you ever go into a pit of poisonous
snakes and then bury your head in the
sand is they're all just sort
of fucking slither and pasture?
Um, uh, yeah. And just things can go down.
This things down there. They can literally
swallow you whole or bite you in half.
And they are, you know what,
a thousand times faster than you.
Um,
yeah, I mean say what you want
about flying. Like I, you know,
the altitude I fly at like I
don't, I can, I can still breathe.
I don't need any assisted or pressurized
cabin or anything like that. This, it's,
it's, you know, you don't, you pick
your poison, but I'll tell you like, uh,
there's a couple of things that
I watch that just, you know,
literally make my palm sweat.
One of them is cave diving.
And if you ever want
to just just, you know,
hear the most unbelievable story ever.
I,
I forget that that fighter's name. He's
actually one of my favorite UFC fighters.
Um,
what is his name?
Cowboys something. Um, okay.
Is it from like New Mexico or whatever?
He's just like the one of the
baddest dudes ever. He never, um, he,
he caved dies and he was on
the Joe Rogan experience. Uh,
just look up Joe Rogan
experience, uh, cave
diving and just listened
to that fucking story.
MMM.
And you're literally listening to the
guy they went through at sea, you know,
somehow he lives, but still, you're like,
I was literally sitting there, you know,
when you do that thing,
when you put your hands like over your
nose and your mouth to sit in there and
you're cute,
your index fingers or between your eyes.
I was just sitting there like
they just covering my mouth,
just listening to this fucking story.
The guy literally said that they have a
rule down there that when someone gets
in trouble in a cave dive, you just
leave them because someone's going home,
someone's going to make it home because,
okay.
It's so fucked up down there that if
you try to help that person than both of
you are going to die.
MMM.
That's kind of how it starts. And
then it goes from there. So anyways,
uh,
okay.
Yeah, cave diving. And then, um,
those people who do that free climbing
up skyscrapers in every time you think
they're up to,
they make those fucking videos and every
time you think they went up is high.
They're literally on the fucking radio
tower and they just keep going up and up
and up and up and up. And it's just
like, I just sit there like, oh,
right, I don't know how the fuck
anybody can do some shit like that.
So maybe that's why I
said most of what I say,
I saw jaws at a certain age and I just
never got over it. I just never got over.
I'm like, I'm all fucking set on that.
It's so crazy to me. Like, you know
that
would you ever go in,
you know, into the g?
Whatever's left to the jungle in Africa
with is just wild fucking hyenas and
tigers and lions and fucking hyenas and
any God knows fucking what out there.
Would you ever go out there
without a damn weapon?
Okay.
And then you go into the fucking ocean.
No guns worked down there.
Okay.
As far as I know.
Yeah.
But you can have is that stupid little
fucking bow and Arrow contraption.
Alright, now I gotta look up underwater
gun. Is there an underwater guy?
And you can possibly fucking half
sorta fucking list. This is going to put
me on underwater firearm. God dammit.
I'll tell you something.
Human beings don't ever want to be
where they can't fucking kill something.
Are you fucking kidding me?
Look at this thing.
Okay.
Slow motion. Underwater guns. Shark ammo.
Oh God.
Okay.
Jesus Christ.
That's all you need is some fucking
people from Texas going there.
I swear to God, man. One
fucking shark looks at me.
One motherfucker looks at me. I'm
going to fucking, it's God damn
fucking fish brain out.
God made us in his image and he were
asked to us to go forth and multiply and
blast the fucking hammer head
riding his fucking head. Um,
I have to see this now. Slow
motion. Underwater guns. Shark ammo.
All right, you can skip this
ad in three, two, one. Bam.
Here we go. Hey, I'm
a fucking youtube guy.
I'm going to fucking tell you
about shark shit. All right.
This guy's all right.
He's trying out some of them bad ass
gun so you could ever fucking half he
shooting watermelon. Good for
him. Not Shooting any people.
Is the breakdown here. What movies like
sharp NATO, your guns and change, right?
Just get to the,
yeah.
All right. Some happen. I fucking my,
my recorder got full.
I was talking about shooting sharks
in the fucking God damn face, man.
I'll fucking you ani. I'll, I'll give
you another fucking breathing hole.
You fucking whale face mother fucker.
They actually figured out how to do it.
They got like a fucking AK 47.
Okay.
Believe in then.
Do you think you're going to be able
to whip that thing out fast enough?
Ah, Jesus Christ. You know what
I mean? What, what are we doing
the fuck are we doing?
We're underwater shooting fucking guns.
It's sharks.
I Dunno.
I mean, see sir, you know,
I got to tell you something is fucking
nuts as flying is when you go flying,
you don't have to go up there with a
fucking gun cause something's going to eat
you out of the Goddamn sky.
Uh,
there's no fucking bird of prey
that's going to grab onto your, uh,
whatever the fuck you're flying.
MMM.
Anyways, uh, but thank you for
listening to the podcast, but you know,
you are right though. I am a bit
of a hypocrite, but like I said,
most of it is just me being
afraid of the ocean. Uh,
gift list,
pressure bill.
My wife gets mad that I don't tell her
what I want for Christmas or birthdays.
Yeah, well it's a pain in the ass
because then she has to guess anyways,
obviously now the issue is Christmas.
I told her I have everything
I need and like you,
I'm trying to thin out all my junk.
It actually stresses me out because I'm
being led to feel bad for not wanting to,
okay.
Two gifted, something to be gifted.
Something. Just ask her for an experience.
Just ask her, you want to go to a
car show or something like that.
Something we could do together. Just do
that. So she has something. All right.
Uh, we both make a lot of
money and buy whatever we want.
She doesn't need anything either, but
gave me a cute idea of something small.
I guess. She's not a total
bitch and just Jesus, she's big.
She's not even remotely a bitch.
Okay.
Does is complete the,
I would throw this and fucking
bitch court if you even every,
why are we or why did you
waste my time with this?
I guess she's not a total bitch. I
just, and just wants to make me happy.
But in a roundabout way,
it ruins the fun of it sometimes.
How do you deal with this? Um, yeah,
I usually just ask for a
okay.
Inexperienced. It's usually some
place I want to go to. Like, uh, my,
I'm a big fan of a,
yeah.
You know, hamburgers stands like
greasy spoon type places. I don't like,
I'm not a big fan of fancy fucking
restaurants. I mean, I like going there,
whatever, but like, I
love going to like, uh,
you know, there's a couple of places, a
place on bill's Burgers I wanted to go to.
Ironically enough, although I heard
the guy doesn't work there anymore,
but the burgers are still tasty.
Um, I love a great taco truck,
food trucks.
Um,
I like doing Jack Shit like that and
like going to car shows and you know,
I went to a Christmas party at
this custom motorcycle, um, uh,
shop,
uh,
the one that Keanu Reeves bought into
and went down and just like, I mean
to me as an adult,
that was like Christmas.
I went down there and they were talking
about how are they make the parts by
hand and how like a 1200 pound slab of
like aluminum will come in in from that,
like ice sculptors except
it use it with the aluminum.
They make parts for these absolutely
gorgeous motorcycles, arch a r,
c h motorcycles.
And um,
okay.
I Dunno,
like,
I think because I became like a closet
gearhead out here where I don't know how
to do any of that shit, but I could
literally watch somebody work on a car.
Describe how they, Eric the car
guy. I'm a huge fan of his. I, uh,
you know, I love that shit. So
whatever the hell you're into.
She loves you. Just gay. She wants to
give you something. Jesus Christ. Um,
it's like she's going to
buy a desk. Um, anyways,
you got a bottle of booze. You're
like, I dunno. Boxing. Hey,
Billy bank shot the third.
I recently been getting fitter thanks
to training sessions at a boxing gym.
Good for you.
Uh,
in wanting to test myself and try some low
level legal, of course, amateur boxing.
Dude,
there's no fucking reason to get your
bell rung for no fucking money when you're
not going to try to pursue it as a
profession, then be careful now. She goes,
my girlfriend won't allow it. Good for
her. She likens me trying it out to her,
trying outstripping in front of a crowd.
And how against the idea and
how against that idea I'd be,
can't say she's wrong.
Uh, do you recognize,
should try a couple of fights just to
see if I like it and not tell her or do I
respect your wishes and leave it as a,
that doesn't need to be answered.
Um, sir, I would never tell you
not to pursue your dreams, but uh,
I wouldn't do it sneaking around.
I would.
MMM.
Bet the very least tell her that
you're going to do one fight.
MMM.
But you know,
what are you going to,
what if you go when you get your fucking
nose broken and then he got to show up
and try to be like Luca.
All right. My name is Luca.
I live on the second floor. I walked
into a fucking door. You don't have to,
you don't have to do that. Right. Um,
I dunno. I, I, yeah,
communication is always the way to go
with the woman is what I've learned and
I've learned and I keep learning.
And you communicate with them and
through the communication, they'll win.
They'll end up telling you how it's going
to go down because it always goes down
the way they want it to go down.
And that's basically it.
MMM.
And that's basically a dude,
what they say goes.
If you want to stay with them and
it's brutally not fucking fair,
but you're a guy and nobody gives a shit.
So what I would do if you're going
to go ahead and do with it anyways,
I would just,
mmm.
I would just tell her that
you're going to do it.
It's something that you
need to do something.
You need to prove to yourself or
whatever the fuck it is. And, uh,
you know, other than that, keep
moving your head there, buddy. Uh,
overrated living in major cities.
Is there anything worse than a bunch of
losers thinking that if they live where
it's cool to live, that
they're cool too. Ah Dude,
you're preaching to the choir here.
That's what I've done my entire
adult life and I am not cool.
They completely deny the fact that living
on top of one another is frustrating
and unnatural. New York smells
like shit. La is overcrowded.
I New York does it smell like
shit areas of it does. New York,
Manhattan is like a giant
bed bath and beyond.
Now La is definitely overcrowded.
MMM,
absolutely. But I gotta be
honest with you though. Um,
so where are you suggesting to live?
Cause if you get to rural then then
it deck just gets too fucking boring.
MMM.
Your food options, a lot
of options. You know,
you want to go see a band and they're
not going to come anywhere near yet.
Now you gotta jump in a
car for four fucking hours.
I definitely envy people who live in
wide open spaces and shit like that.
Uh, I think it's really cool and I got a
lot of respect for people that live out
there. Like that, but just
living where I've lived, uh,
I don't know how long I could do it.
I go a little fucking stir crazy,
although there's a lot of people
here in la that, you know,
have that second home and
fucking Wyoming or whatever.
Um, but my wife isn't
going to, it would never go
for that self. And she makes
the decisions, um, underrated,
uh, living in midsize cities.
Oh, here's his answer.
There's nothing better than a city
that's not really a city. I, you know,
I'd go with that and I have my favorite
ones. Uh, and these are all cities.
I wouldn't say they're not cities, but
like, uh, I'm a big fan of Milwaukee,
uh, Chattanooga. Um,
what else comes to mind?
Uh,
those are two of my favorites.
Is that it? I think so. I mean,
I enjoyed when I was up
in Idaho and Montana.
MMM.
It just seems like nobody
really fucks with the up there,
but then they had like a massive math
problem. So there's always something.
There's always something,
you know what I mean?
MMM.
I just switched with all the
fucking global warming like that.
I just wish that there,
those people could still enjoy the
climates that they moved there for. Um,
cause, you know, just growing up on the
east coast and everything, I think it's,
you know, I missed the four
seasons and shit. And, uh,
I also think it's really cool to kind of
live out in places like that. You know,
having said that, you know, the
experiences that I've gotten living in La,
this is one of my favorite cities.
And I also love New York as much as
I make fun of both of these cities.
MMM.
Where else? You know, I, you
know, living in a sports town,
I'll tell you what's under rated two
FTE move away is going back and live in
your fucking home state again.
You know,
when you don't have to get by
all the fucking sports packages,
just to watch a regular season, game me
a team as pretty fucking overrated too.
Um, all right. That's the podcast
for this week. A Merry Christmas.
Happy Hanukkah. Oh, Hanukkah is going
on right now. Happy Hanukkah, everybody.
And uh,
go fuck yourselves and I'll
check in on you on Thursday.